Yes.
My name is Mul Alen.
>> Mulina Alen and you are a student.
>> Please go ahead with your question.
>> Okay. My question is uh throughout life
we may go through many wounds and
traumas and the traumas would transform
into hatred in our unconscious mind. So
uh it it whether whether it's towards
our siblings or our brotherhood or even
our parents.
So my question is what is the ruling in
Islam regarding this hidden feeling of
hatred even when we still try to treat
others well like the best trait to our
parents but deep inside it feels heavy
to do so because of the emotional burden
from the past traumas.
The sisters asked the question that
there are some feelings and that
feelings get converted to trauma and the
trauma converted gets converted into
hatred. So what should we do with
certain feelings system? I talk today
was based on that that many people have
feelings based on race on color. Some
people don't like because the person is
black. They don't like because he's
poor. They don't like because he's
short. And this feeling then you start
thinking I'm superior
then it gets converted into trauma then
converted into hatred. So all these are
wrong. The only thing that can make you
superior is tawa. So my talk was based
on that and I do agree with you. This
then causes disruption of the universal.
So when you have this feeling if it's
wrong you have to suppress this feeling.
Why are you letting that feeling convert
into a trauma? Then drama into hatred.
Stop. You have to nip it at the butt.
When you get these feelings, you have to
do these feelings are wrong. These arean
these are the vasa of the shaitan. So
these feelings which are based on
superiority or you know feeling of
trauma then converts into hatred. You
have to see the source
and you have to base it. Keep Quran as
your guide.
Whatever matches with the Quran we agree
we follow the Quran. What Quran says is
further than must we like the person.
The more tawa is the more we respect
him.
So it is our fault that we are allowing
such feelings to nurture in ourselves
convert into a trauma then convert into
hatred. Who's to blame? We are to blame.
>> Okay. So you should suppress it at the
beginning that these areas of the
shaitan
really if the person is good okay he's a
he's quoting the Quran he's after the
Quran mashallah good
and if really doing things which are bad
he may be alcoholic he may be a gambler
okay then but if he's your relative you
have to dava with them
if your friend becomes alcoholic it's
your duty to get her on the state path
not hit her get her on the straight
path. So why what is the benefit of
hitting someone?
So your job is to see to it that if your
relative or if your friend has gone on
the wrong track, you have to get them on
the right track and you should not feel
superior and have hatred. So if you
follow the guidelines of the Quran,
inshallah you'll be on the straight path
and you'll be able to spread more peace.
Hope that answers the question.